the sale of mgm to amazon might be just
around the corner
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so as we know
amazon have agreed to buy mgm in a deal
that's worth around a billion dollars
but this deal has been locked up in the
regulators in the united states
other regulators around the world have
already agreed this deal and said that
this deal can go ahead but the american
regulators are dragging their feet
this has been going on already for
nearly six months and a lot of insiders
have suggested that it could drag on
until the summer of 2022 at very least
some have even suggested that the
regulators might actually block the sale
now they're using competition rules as
the excuse for that they're basically
saying that this would create a monopoly
where we are right now is kind of a
legal limbo technically in some ways
amazon already owns mgm and
actually in some areas like australia
for example they're already allowed to
operate as the owners because the
regulators have agreed the deal
but mgm is based and its world
headquarters is in the united states and
most of its business is done in the
united states so it's only really that
regulator that really matters
so where are we right now well i can
tell you that i actually have sources
within mgm they've been talking to me
over the last few weeks they have told
me some quite interesting news
that actually there are a lot of
meetings planned this week
the meetings are between amazon and mgm
because they want to figure out how to
move this forwards
now amazon actually have agreed with the
regulators that all major mgm
productions going forwards will be based
in the united states this is not an
official agreement it's sort of an under
table part of the negotiation but it was
agreed basically because it's felt by
amazon that a big reason why the
regulators are dragging their feet is
because of amazon's reputation of not
really paying its fair way tax-wise
they feel that it's because of their
business ethics that the regulators are
completely against them
and don't want the deal to go through
so
if they agree that all major productions
going forwards
are based in the united states this will
create jobs create income and obviously
generate tax dollars
now that is a big thing actually for
stargate
stargate is the main reason why i'm
keeping a big eye on what's going on
with amazon and mgm because i've been
told that as soon as the amazon mgm deal
goes through and is finalized the
stargate will be green lit we will get a
movie and a tv series really really
quickly
the longer this drags on might change
those plans but that is the plan that is
the idea that is the hope
so what is the point of the meetings in
the next week well
according to my sources amazon are
actually exploring two major avenues
firstly they want to try to figure out
with mgm what else could be done to try
to loosen the wheels up with the
regulators what else could they offer
secondly they're actually looking at
possible legal action
if if the deal drags on for much longer
they are considering taking the
regulator and basically the american
government to court
they want to take it to arbitration to
have the deal either agreed or thrown
out and they're sick of waiting for the
regulators to do it they believe
actually the regulators are behaving the
way they are for political reasons not
for legal reasons
now i actually think they've got a
really good point i don't understand why
the regulator has taken so long to make
this decision and mgm are making the
point that actually it's costing them
money they are losing money hand over
fist because they can't agree any major
contracts they can't move forward with
any major new projects for example
stargate is supposed to be in production
but it can't be because of this
regulator problem
so they're saying we're losing money you
are crippling this business with your
actions
you're talking about competition but
really this is a political motivation
it needs to stop we need to move
forwards and as i say other countries
like australia in the united kingdom and
other places around the world have
already agreed this deal it's already
gone through the regulators and they
don't see any problem with it
amazon are only arguing that the united
states for some reason does have a
problem and that that has got nothing to
do with actual monopolies or
cornering any markets it's actually
because the regulators don't like the
way amazon does business
but talking to the people at mgm i
really do get a feel that
they believe this deal is going to go
through sooner rather than later that
we're talking about weeks not months
it was a big breakthrough having this
agreement with the regulators that
they're going to shift production into
the united states
that really seem to
show that amazon want to do things a
certain way and that they want
and that maybe they understand the
problems the regulators have with the
way they do business
now i don't think that'll be a long-term
thing i think amazon knows the value of
a dollar and they'll squeeze out the
best they can the main reason why
stargate was produced in vancouver in
the first place was because of cost
production cost
so what do i think is going to happen
moving forwards
i think these meetings in the next week
are going to be really interesting i'm
hoping i'll find a few more little
tidbits to if i can share with you once
those meetings have happened
i want to get more of a feeling of what
mgm and the amazon executives really
believe is going to happen over the next
few months and then hopefully that'll
give us an idea of when we can expect
this deal to go through
i think we're bound to start hearing
more leaks and more information coming
out of amazon because they're going to
want to start shifting the public
opinion into their favor if they can so
i believe that we'll start here in
stores through the mainstream media as
well
the main thing is though with this if
this deal does go through the next few
weeks the people at mgm are telling me
that stargate and a couple of other
projects including james bond
is really important to amazon and they
want to push it through as quickly as
possible
they want to start shifting the public
opinion into their favor and how better
to do that than to announce big projects
that will get people excited
so please leave a comment tell me what
you think how long do you think this
process is going to go do you actually
believe the deal will be finalized or do
you think the regulators could actually
block it
and if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit the bell notification
share the video wherever the hell you
like and as always guys please stay safe
i'll see you really soon